bonsoir à tous je crois qu'une des
raisons d'être d' apostrophes c'est de
réunir pour qu'ils parlent pour qui les
évoquent des souvenirs pour qu'ils
confrontent des souvenirs et des idées
des auteurs qui appartenaient les
générations différentes provenant
d'horizons souvent opposées ne seraient
jamais rencontrés sans cette opportunité
par exemple ce soir pour évoquer les
espoirs de leurs 20 ans un romancier un
soldat un historien et un
révolutionnaire
voici le 155e nude apostrophe les années
de vos 20 ans
le plus ancien c'est le soldat le
colonel roger trinquier qui a eu 20 ans
en 1928 donc né en 1908 vous avez été en
poste successivement au tonkin en chine
en indochine en algérie
vous avez été c'est vous qui avez créé
le 1er bataillon de parachutistes
coloniaux les bérets rouges et fameux
béret rouge
vous êtes commandeur de la légion
d'honneur 14 citations vous êtes
l'auteur d'une demi-douzaine d'ouvragés
le dernier paru aux éditions albin
michel sous le titre le temps perdu
c'est une autobiographie militaires et
politiques à côté de vous votre cadet de
deux ans c'est le romancier d'écrivain
il s'agit d'henri queffélec
vous avez vu vingt ans vous en 1937 née
en 1910 vous êtes romancier grand prix
du roman de l'académie française poète
vous avez écrit aussi de des essais des
biographies et bien d'autres livres et
votre dernier ouvrage est paru chez
stock sous le titre c'est une sont des
souvenirs sous le titre un breton bien
tranquille avec la collaboration de
maurice chauvet ardèche
l'historien alors là nous entrons chez
dans la génération beaucoup plus
récentes et d'historiens c'est michel
winoc qui a eu 20 ans en 1957 donc né en
vous êtes vous enseigner l'histoire
contemporaine de l'université de
vincennes
vous êtes rédacteur en chef de la revue
l'histoire vous êtes l'auteur de trois
livres d'histoire sur les communes à la
troisième république et la revue esprit
et vous avez publié aux éditions du
seuil la république se meurt qu'une
chronique des années 56 58
et puis le plus jeune c'est le
révolutionnaire le révolutionnaire c'est
dire jean pierre le dantec qui lui a eu
20 en 1963 donc née pendant la guerre en
43 est un ancien militant maoïste
fondateur avec d'autres de la gauche
prolétarienne condamné à un an de prison
en 1970 comme directeur de la cause du
peuple
actuellement saignant à l'unité
pédagogique architecture numéro 6 de
paris et vous avez publié un livre sur
la bretagne est votre seul au second
livre vient de paraître aux presses
d'aujourd'hui sous le titre les dangers
du soleil
si vous étiez dans corps comme unis je
dirais que c'est un livre d'autocritique
oui elle ça évidemment et le plus simple
peut être pour l'expliquer précisément
ces deux de partir du titre le titre qui
a semblé un peu ésotérique à certaines
mes amis je suis parti de d'un conte de
lysel recueillis par lysel barde breton
du 19e siècle qui avait recueilli donc
une série de contes dans lesquels il y
en a un qui s'appelle les voyages vers
le soleil et je me suis rappelé que dans
la mythologie révolutionnaire le soleil
a toujours représenté l'issue vers vers
où le révolutionnaire se dresse ce qui
oriente sa marche
à preuve par exemple que c'est tout ont
été comparés au soleil rouge des du
peuple chinois
luminet tout le peuple chinois donc il
s'agit de de notre soleil de mont soleil
oui et de maquettes
cette marche vers vers le soleil et 7 au
terme sinon au terme de cette de cette
quête une réflexion une sinon une remise
en cause de mes motivations du moins
un retour sur la problématique
révolutionnaire elle même en ce qu'elle
peut conduire à du totalitarisme
vous dites aussi c'est la bafin leurs
essais récits de l'exploration là je
vous cite des entrailles puante de la
politique absolue oui la conscience
politique absolue où ce que d'autres de
mes amis appellent la conception
politique du monde sam après la même
chose c'est cette conception du monde
que nous avions tous de ma génération
enfin tous tous ceux qui sont engagés
comme moi dans le sur la même voie
c'est à dire une pensée à partir d'un
postulat que tout est politique dans
tous les rapports humains a un côté qui
est à rattacher aux notions de pouvoir
et donc à la politique
nous avions pensé qu' à travers l'idée
de la ligne de masse demain c'est tout
c'est à dire prendre les idées du bas
les synthétiser et reformer une
politique qui à partir de là permet
d'agir sur le monde pour le transformer
nous avons pensé qu' on pouvait agir de
cette façon par une conception politique
du monde très strictes une
transformation de la réalité sociale
de fait comme la plupart de mes amis je
me suis aperçu que ce n'était pas si
simple
nous y reviendrons nous y reviendrons
c'est d'ailleurs je vous appelle et
allusion à cette autocritique à la
statistique oui aux michel vinoble je
vous ai présenté comme un historien mais
leur ce livre n'est pas du tout le livre
d'un historien c meme je sui rencontré
un effet plein subjectivité à livre très
personnel
d'ailleurs il a pour sous titre
chronique chronique 1956 1958 et j'ai
voulu indiquer par ce sous titre
justement le caractère subjectif de mon
livre
au départ il y a des carnets des carnets
que je tenais très régulièrement que
j'écrivais oui entre entre 16 et 23 24
ans des carnets qui se sont entassés
dans des tiroirs que j'ai un peu oublié
et puis un beau jour je me suis remis à
feuilleter cela est pas tout à fait par
hasard parce que je mettais là j'étais
enseignant comme vous l'avez dit je suis
enseignant et je m'étais aperçu petit à
petit que
mes références mais référence
c'est-à-dire les références de mes 20
ans n'était plus celle de mon public et
ça c'est fait insensiblement au départ
en effet l'enseignant il est très proche
de ses de ses étudiants des élèves
j'étais professeur de lycée 24 ans donc
j'avais des élèves de 18 19 ans je me
sentais de la même génération de presse
et puis insensiblement progressivement
il y a les cards entre deux générations
qui se constitue qui se creusent et cela
ce ne se fait pas brutalement mais un
beau jour on découvre et dans mon cas
c'était un unité de valeur un court si
vous préférez que je faisais sur la sur
la quatrième république et je
m'apercevais que toutes les choses qui
était ma vie comme tout le monde deux en
tout cas d'étudiants d'histoire ne
l'était pas et des références très
simple très concrète par exemple le nom
d'un journal le nom d'un journaliste où
l'aspect l'aide d'un journal
c'était les années 50 on était vraiment
des années des grands hebdomadaires de
gauche c'étaient les langes fraises de
jadis etc or ces journaux là il ne les
connaissait que dans leur version
d'aujourd'hui qui n'a pas grand chose à
voir avec ce que c'était jeudi
donc je me suis dit j'ai envie de leur
dire non pas comme un professeur
je n'ai pas envie de faire un court
puisque je le faisais un bitume mais
j'ai envie de leur dire ce que moi vingt
ans du 19 20 ans j'éprouvais quelles
étaient mes passions les étaient mes
problèmes et essai rédigé un livre et
ses passions coïncidait avec une période
particulièrement tourmenté deux
histoires de france c'est à dire la
période 56 58 colonel trinquier j'ai
présenté votre livre en disant que
c'était une autobiographie militaire et
politique
on est d'accord pas tout à fait j'ai pas
voulu faire une autobiographie
j'ai voulu raconter les événements que
j'ai vu à l'âge que j'avais et au point
de vue géographique où je me trouvais
c'est à dire la guerre 14-18 jeu début
j'avais des six habitants de mon village
j'étais pas sur le front ensuite j'ai
commandé pas sur la frontière de chine
les déchets doit envoyer les événements
qui se déroulaient en france avec le
centre rapidement les ouvriers je les
raconte telle que j'ai les rouilles à ce
point de vue ensuite j'étais sur les
marginaux comme office
j'ai vu ce que valait l'armée française
en 1138 au mode munnich ensuite j'ai tu
allais à pékin à pékin je commandais
deux compagnies lagarde ambassade de
france à pékin
toutes les ambassades du monde était
dans le même carré et le soir les gens
tous des armes au sein du monde se
rassembler dans le même carré j'ai eu
des amis allemands des amis de toutes
les nationalités et la guerre est venue
dans cette atmosphère où nous en
discutions les uns des hommes d'après
j'étais à schirmeck pendant six ans
ensuite j'y raconte les événements
auxquels j'ai participé et comme acteur
roma terme acteurs seniors qui ont
concerné comme auteur j'ai fait la
guerre et du shérif pendant quatre ans
des points différents a tué deux massifs
en abattage et commandé un régiment
donc c'est un témoignage cet arrêté
moyens c'est un moteur j'ai essayé de
faire abstraction de ma personnalité
pour mieux raconter les événements
nombreuses communes où l'abstraction
faire un probable que j'essayais
d'affaires attraction le plus possible
sur les personnes et est ce que j'ai
fait dramatique personnes personnes mais
ce que j'ai fait au point du politique
si vous voulez ça oui c'est disposer que
je dis autobiographique politique et
militaire j'ai pas dis à ta biographie
sentimentale ou rien d'autre les
insultes qui voulaient cherrier au
katanga
cette personne et vous le raconter je la
raconte aussi et j'ai vu aussi les
événements mai 68 on n'a pas peur on en
parlera bien sûr lots henri queffélec
envie de quitter fennecs pour un breton
bien tranquille et vous dites que
pourtant vous avez écrit beaucoup de
l'ouvragé vous dire que vous devez
beaucoup à ce livre de souvenirs
oui énormément parce que il m'a obligé à
repenser un peu à toute ma vie je n'ai
pas le temps d'y penser tellement je
vivais une fois puis d'autre part
j'écrivais les romans une lance à
intéresser énormément de faire revivre
tous les compagnons de
mon enfance de ma jeunesse et vous même
et oui et d'apercevoir l'unité l'unité
de ma vie je sais bien que on a rigolé
un peu de ce bien tranquille on en abuse
peut-être un peu vieillot lui alors
peut-être peut-être sept autres bretons
les dents face de vous monsieur le
dantec
c'est à dire que le lit on n'a pas
l'impression qu'il ya eu il a plutôt une
vie assez mouvementée mais s'il me
rendre ici parce que je pense en effet
que puisqu'on dirait monsieur nous avons
pris le terme de révolutionnaire que la
première révolution c'est d'abord celle
que l'on fait sur soi et je pense que je
n'ai pas manqué à la règle
d'ailleurs en étant chrétien et
simplement en étant fidèle aux valeurs
que j'avais apprise des miens pendant
mon enfance parce que mes années vous
avez étendu le terme de vingt ans vous
avez dit louis 18 30 ans c'est le
précisément c'est à ce moment là que je
suis devenu breton que je le savais je
l'étais mais je ne savais pas et c'était
la nostalgie monsieur winoc quelquefois
là mais un petit peu en boîte mais pour
ma part je prends la nostalgie une
puissance merveilleuse au point de vue
littéraire et pour ma part moi je lui
rends hommage c'est grâce à la nostalgie
apparu que j'ai senti vraiment maxime
bretonne oui c'est à dire ça rime à
paris que vous avez considéré que
finalement vous avez perçu vous étiez
breton comme d'autres vont à l'étranger
et ce moment s'aperçoit qu'ils sont
français
voilà et après quand j'étais en suède
alors c'est si j'étais français et nous
votons bon à 16 ans vous avez votre
bachelot et vous obtenez une bourse pour
venir à paris au lycée louis le grand et
vous y passez je crois trois ans vous
raconter et là vous rencontrez alors
vraiment des écrivains qui ont laissé un
nom la littérature française j'en sommes
quelques-uns y a pas existé peut-être
pas tous dans votre promotion m'enfin
vous avez connu brasillach roger
vailland christian rebert maire thierry
monnier senghor or ces six écrivains ont
non seulement ce sont de bons écrivains
mais ils ont tous eu une influence
politique dans le siècle
regardez je vous le répète roger
bazillac et yang robert maire thierry
monnier senghor et pas vous alors vous
vous n'aviez pas la tête politique
comment ça se fait oui mais sur un des
six tout de même je ferai des réserves
ces vaillants je sais bien qu'il ya eu
apparemment
comme ça faciès révolutionnaire mais en
fait pour moi je crois que c'était un
artiste un dilettante avant tout et je
ne le considère pas comme un véritable
politique
alors il en reste 5 mai par exemple si
je prenais senghor
l'autre jour encore j'ai eu l'occasion
de l'entendre de près et il a dit que
pour lui la politique tout le monde on
est essoufflé mais que c'était un à-côté
qu'en réalité il était poète sait que
c'était cela essentiellement compter
pour hui que la politique c'était ça
venait après oui oui mais oui d'accord
mais vous nous dit finalement que la
politique ça ne compte pas à ça ne
compte pas ça qui peut compter pour moi
c'est un petit peu quand il faut aussi
ça annonce a compté un peu pour moi ce
moment là mais vraiment et de la
politique politicienne en tout cas la
grande politique face à elle comptera
toujours quoique vous dites à me manque
à 15 ans vous avez été tenté par
l'action française oui mais pour des
raisons religieuses
oui pour des raisons religieuses parce
que j'ai j'ai cru à ce moment là qu on
allait prendre des mesures contre les
ordres religieux en france et alors j'ai
été sensible à certaines sirènes qu'il
fait savoir que du temps des rois
c'était pas comme ça t'aidera
et d'ailleurs puisque j'ai appartenu à
la revue esprit le royalisme en tant que
tel je ne le renie pas comme une
possibilité c'est autre chose c'est très
très large au point de vue social mais
veut dire que pour la grande politique
je ne fais pas de distinction comme cela
mais en 1932 aux élections ou mettez un
bulletin nul dans l'urne
vous avez oui vous avez 22 ans oui mais
ça c'est un peu comme ce qu'a dit andré
gide n'est ce pas choisir me paraissait
non tant les lire que repousser ce que
je ne lisais pas à ce moment là on est
beaucoup plus sensible à l'aspect
critique ce jeu j'étais à l'école
le canular sévices et nous étions
extrêmement sensible à un rien du tout
n'est ce pas un détail ridicule
suffisait pour enlever tout poids à un
homme qui était pourtant très grave et
très sérieux ça alors vous savez non je
crois qu'il y avait quinze candidats
dans mon arrondissement
à regarder leurs affiches moi je sais
pas se trouve que c'était un salmigondis
me suis dit faut qu est ce que je vais
voter là dedans gelée que non mais vous
apparteniez aussi est ce que vous
appelez les équipes sociales ça ça
comptait alors énormément pour moi oui
oui ça c'était le mouvement qui avait
été lancé par robert garric et qui peut
se maintenant enfin se réjouir d'avoir
aidé beaucoup à l'évolution de michel
muchez le mini souris blinis pakistan
devient à michelet a été des équipes
socialiste passait par lui au fond que
vous pouvez voir un peu ce que c'était
que ce mouvement qui avait bien sûr et
moi aussi puisque j'étais sensible au
ridicule j'aurais pu le blaguer et dire
que c'est ça sentait un peu trop le
scoutisme
mais c'était un mouvement d'une
générosité très belle mais vous êtes un
jeune homme heureux parce que vous êtes
donc au lycée will quand vous dites j'ai
travaillé beaucoup j'avais d'excellents
camarades et l'excellente professeurs
vous êtes ensuite anormal et vous dit ce
qu'il emportait rue d'ulm c'était la
simplicité la gentillesse il est heureux
partout oui mais je oui c'est un
reproche qui lui donne envie non mais il
s'estime est mouillé que au fond que
quand vous parlez des entrailles puantes
n'est ce pas de la politique à la fin au
fond vous vous aspirer au bonheur j'ai
été très sensible à la fin de votre
livre très très sensible c'est des
poussettes aux découvertes des crevettes
à la fin n'est ce pas ce bonheur tout
simple la fin tout cet itinéraire
formidable que vous avez fait pour
revenir constater avec que c'est beau de
pêcher la crevette de la fouille est
comme ça dessous les herbiers sur scène
alors vous vous avez finalement toujours
eu le bonheur de la crevette oui
toujours
oui d'ailleurs je suis sûr que tous ici
aussi non
le colonel denfert 3 dans son livre les
corvette non non il ya peu de crevettes
dans le livre du pied se connecter
comment autant qu'un il y en avait pour
les invasions oui
l'hérésie a été peuplée de poisson je
vais pêcher d'un péché un autre
plus gros poisson boeing et oui vous est
par exemple vous allez en 1930 a pas
besoin d'aller en algérie et vous noté
nous avons une quinzaine de camarades
invités pour les fêtes du centenaire de
l'algérie je confesse que durant le beau
voyage je n'ai pas pressenti l'évolution
de l'histoire je ne soupçonnais ni
l'attention ni la tension sociale et la
tension politique temps en temps dans
votre livre vous dites
ben oui la politique m'échappe j'en suis
loin oui remarqué mes camarades aussi
non non non rien vu pas davantage
essayez ton coin de thé vous ça alors je
dis puisque vous avez lu avec tellement
d'attention ligne vous avez vu que là
l'histoire m'avait intéressé énormément
donné que j'ai failli me spécialiser en
histoire et l'histoire a tout le temps
toute ma vie comme la géographie
d'ailleurs n'a existé beaucoup et
l'histoire par conséquent je suis malgré
tout je suis bien obligé de m'intéresser
à la politique si vous n'êtes pas un
polémiste vous le dit amara nom du break
quelqu'un ma taille je ne réponds pas je
ne peux par exemple les décomptes de
rebatet vous exaspère vous venez d'un
mois je vais été créé pour répondre et
puis non je ne pouvais pas le faire là
oui mais vous ne l'aurions pas fait tout
ça
allez avouez c'est pas parce que j'ai eu
même par des nouvelles si je ne sais pas
si elle de lui beaucoup à eux
l'humour noir quelques fois j'en ai
quand même usé enfin vous n'êtes pas
engagée dans le siècle
non mais de ça j'ai assisté beaucoup
là-dessus municipal l'engagement
dégagement je crois que mounier lui
aussi sur la fin de sa vie vet opéré un
mouvement de recul et que c'était une
des grandes caractéristiques des des
écrivains français que de attentes
attend toujours lorsqu'il était lancé
dans la lutte politique tout de même de
montrer qu'ils n'étaient pas pris à fond
par la défense des idées qui avait
d'autres choses mais je trouve votre
type très juste vous êtes effectivement
à 20 ans un jeune homme un breton bien
tranquille
non
bien tranquille vous chine et au sens de
ce sera recueillie s'il voulait mais pas
et qu'ils se dirigent à l'écriture
weekes est le riz vers l'écriture mais
mes pas pas content de soi pas alors m'a
satisfait chargé je n'ai pas dit content
de soi dont j'ai effectivement mais on
sent que le bonheur d'aller le
rechercher dans la solitude de
l'écriture oui et vous décidez sound et
si vraiment à quel âge où celle ci je
crois que lesdits c'est pendant le cours
d'anglais ou pendant la seconde heure du
cours d'anglais où je n'en pouvais plus
et ça m'intéressait beaucoup mais je les
était fatigué alors je je me suis mis à
écrire des poèmes en prose et c'est de
là que tout est venu
ça a commencé comme ça alors le dantec
jean-pierre dantec le breton comment
vous semble-t-il l'impression qu'il ya
vraiment beaucoup de générations entre
vous deux différences parce
qu'évidemment vous avez pas une vie
quand on me parle de lavaux tout à fait
rond c'est pas du tout la même chose ça
ne sont pas si éloignés que ça voyez
vous il y a eu quand j'ai lu le livre de
café de québec
je me suis senti très proche de lui à
bien des égards très proche parent
finalement même si nos mythologie perse
familiales sont assez éloignées puisque
vous venez d'un milieu catholique eux
très chrétien me semble-t-il émois d'un
mieux de milieu le communiste
reste qu' il y à des données
fondamentales comme la mer limites
enfin toute une série de deux de
profondeur
je ne trouve pas d'autres mots qui
finalement tissent entre nous des liens
mais jean-pierre d'amphores auriez vous
dis la même chose quand vous aviez 20
ans non certainement pas je leur ai pas
dit la même chose parce que là vous
l'auriez envoyé aux pelotes des flèches
c'est possible c'est sûrement le temps
que oui c'est possible d'autant que mais
sûrement assez naturel assez virulent
virulence rare oui je l'aurais fait
vraisemblablement parce que précisément
la bretagne à ce moment là la bretagne
que je vivais à mes 20 ans c'était
évidemment tout est issu de souvenirs
d'enfance mais c'était aussi quelque
chose qui me semblait très très
étouffant à l'époque
bon j'étais je vais terminer mes études
au lycée ou au lycée de châteaubriant de
rennes où je faisais pas calmé les
métaux les mathématiques et j'avais
énormément envie d'aller à paris
je vais m'ennuyer profondément dans
cette danse est top et je m'ennuyais à
rennes et j'avais le désir de paris
comme un provincial classique du 19e
siècle qui a envie d'aller à paris parce
que il pense qu'il va y trouver quelque
chose de d'extraordinaire et en fait bon
il ya fallu tout un tout un itinéraire
qui est moi raconté dans mon livre pour
que la bretagne me se referme sur moi à
nouveau au fond et vous rejoignez en
bretagne au bord de la mer oui échappé
bel âge aurait invité ya dix ans laurier
mairie non je crois fille se noircit pas
ce que je vais écouter quand on vous
voit enfin une méchante énorme non non
non à la pression vous êtes rigolard
aussi est ce que votre livre est drôle
alors quand même c'est pas possible non
non rien le prêt de mes chances bon on
va voir si le colonel trinquier tahri
goalard comme vous dites vous
vous êtes au fond la question j'ai vu de
poser tous etc comment un fils de
paysans des hautes-alpes choisi le
métier des armes
et parce que j'avais pas de votre choix
c'est simple mon choix moi j'aurais fait
n'importe quoi dans la vie j'étais
militaire j'ai essayé très bon militaire
mais dans les dents les lois de
l'enseignement avant la guerre est bien
mais l'enseignement primaire
on était bloqués alors je suis allé à
l'école primaire supérieure parce que
mes parents m'ont envoyé à l'école
normale je me suis aperçu qu'on était
bloqué il y avait aucune sortie jack
semaine quand je la constate et notre
savoir avec nos camarades ont été au
moins leurs égaux quand on était dans la
même école et c'était fini
l'enseignement primaire étaient bloquées
et j'avais qu'une sortie c'était être
militaire je voulais certaines maps est
un instituteur soul et paraissait
l'enseignement je me voyais pas moi 20
ans continue et même été jusqu'à 60 ans
je dis ça je pourrais pas le faire alors
j'avais une sortie c'était les verts le
l'élève officier de réserve et rester
dans l'armée mais à saison vous aviez
déjà été de politique
ah oui ça j'ai toujours d'abord web en
libye j'ai toujours suivi de près tous
les événements politiques ou que je sois
vous étiez pour pré carré j'étais prêt à
l'école normale dans ma promotion
nous avons voté en 1128 moi je me suis
présenté poincaré est un de mes
camarades où donc est toujours mon
camarade s'est présenté pour le cartel
des gauches nous avons dix mois chacun
et déjà cette époque vous alliez 16 ans
nous faisions des conférences dans les
combles vous étiez déjà pour eux contre
une politique d'abandon entre guillemets
on peut pas dire ces points ont été
complétés avant vis-à-vis de la manne en
santé que le tout le gouvernement lâche
et tous vis-à-vis des monnaies jeu mais
si vous voulez l'année 1121 c'est le
jour noir de la france d'après-guerre
loos le cartel des gauches est arrivé
c'est pas une question de gauche mais à
partir au mans nous avoir abandonnés
larigot juin c'était le début de la
dégringolade
et si je mets le jour noir je vous dis
si vous savez peut-être succès c'était
mode lui d'un d'or si vous ne savez je
lui d'abord appelé le jour noir de
l'allemagne 8 août 1918 parce que les
français avaient lancé une offensive
moyenne et lui s'est aperçu qu'il ait
plus de réserves que c'était fini la
paix s'est lui tout du jour noir vermeer
demandez moi j'appelle le 11 mai 1924 le
jour noir de la france accepte on s'est
passée la bombe
c'était le début de la dégringolade
la souche je pensais qu'on aurait dû
garder la roue alors jeune basque étant
donné qu'on savait que militaire on a
tous nous prépare la guerre contre
l'allemagne
et quand on pas la guerre contre man il
faut pas lui laisser des armes tout de
suite il faut pas laisser ces armes et
là on a vu où nous sommes nous amener
nous sommes arrivés désormais contre la
mère entretenait va tomber à venir vous
avez quelques questions mais simplement
pourquoi vous choisissez les l'armée
coloniale et parce que je ne sais pas je
voulais voir je vous demande je suis je
sais pas du tout mais je voulais voir du
pays il ya un après la réforme yable
quand on est jeune voir sortir son prix
sortir de france voire plus donc
connaître d'autres populations voire
d'autres genres et donc vous allez
connaître effectivement du pays puisque
pour votre premier poste depuis huit ans
ne convenait pas sur la frontière de
chine autant qu'elle tonkin et c'est un
grand souvenir dans votre vie mais là
parce que j'ai vu on a été si vous
voulez les derniers seigneurs féodaux
c'est à dire que fait j'étais le wild
audience sur feu doux au sens même du
moyen âge si vous voulez on avait toutes
les fonctions j'étais médecin j'étais
pharmaciens j'étais jeune on faisait
tout et on vit au mieux la population
comme si j'avais avec moi de
sous-officier français le reste ans
étaient des autochtones et tout le long
de la frontière j'avais 400 partisans
c'était des jeunes gens à qui je donne
un mousqueton 1 30 cartouches qui avait
toujours chez eux et notre but c'était
de protéger ces populations contre les
chinois quand les pirates chinois est
depuis des siècles les chinois qui est
une race et une grande race une race
supérieure si loulou vietnamien on sent
tout de suite quand on a franchi la
frontière d'un côté c'est notre lot et
lumière et chinois c'est un grand peuple
je pourrais pas en dire autant des biens
de mieux c'est à mon peuple si vous les
mettez pas un grand peuple et bien
les chips si je voyais les chinois
avaient l'habitude de venir piratés chez
les vietnamiens il essaie faire iso et
pas se défendre et nous nous le
défendrons avec eux d'ailleurs mais
alors là vous parler un petit peu de
votre vie sentimentale puisque
vous racontez que eh bien il était
normal que le chef du post ils
choisissent une une indigène et les
choses ne sais pas c'était un choix qui
était du côté vous avez une femme
pendant votre wii et wii en meute et
justement dans les poches des
célibataires pour qu'on se marie avec
une faillite du pays parce que les
femmes comptent dans la vie d'un homme
et dans les postes à l'intérieur où il y
avait des capitaines marié et bien il
avait eu aucun contact avec la femme
faisait écran les femmes qui se
dévouaient le métier la teinture du lot
sur les femmes des gosses et les
sauniers meinau tadic
une femme indigène c'était la
représentante de moi dans la population
et les habitants qui auraient jamais osé
venir me voir l'unité il faut dès que tu
dis ça au lieu dans hung et je voudrais
le voir mais quand lieutenant repartait
il redonnait une somme d'argent à la
cédraie d'accord à sa jolie veuve s'est
présentée parce qu'elle ne reverra
jamais ah oui ça c'est certain alors il
ya des choses qu est ce que ça vous
choque aujourd'hui c'est bien ça m'a
choqué c'est à dire que jamais écrit ça
alors je vous dis quand je l'avais écrit
j'écris ça il ya longtemps j'ai pris des
notes et bien je suis juge estimé qu'au
début j'étais peut-être moins humain que
je suis aujourd'hui oui alors
aujourd'hui à bien peu de regrets de ces
choses à donges et je m'aperçois que
c'est une femme qui n'était attachée
comme j'ai été attaché on peut pas vivre
de zinc une femme qui vous est dévouée
sans être sans lui est attaché et je
peux dire quand j'ai quitté equiteq
beaucoup de peine est elle aussi est
l'os il ya aucun doute
seulement c'était un contrat comme avait
fait elle savait qu'au bout de deux ans
m'a expliqué son cadre le seigneur de la
guerre repartait repartait reparlait oui
vous alors le arrive le front populaire
monsieur winoc est conçu en 1936 il va
naître en 1937 et pendant ce temps vous
vous dites voilà le programme le plus
démagogiques jamais présenté aux
français il assura le crayon du front
populaire des réformes sociales promises
sur rapidement voté mais elles furent
appliquées dans un climat dié
d'agitation tels que désorganisait pour
plusieurs années notre économie mais
j'ai bien vers une france que ces
mesures au d'état d'esprit depuis
longtemps oui vous êtes
sud rail mais j'aimais pas ce qu'il faut
je suis pas contre les mesures qui ont
été faites ça serait vraiment mais je
vous dis je vois des événements du jeu
les voiliers à ce moment j'étais à pékin
ils font peu plus notre pays évidemment
ces noms ont discuté avec les étrangers
qui étaient là j'ai en discuter avec les
allemands qui se moquaient de nous qui
disait alors que nous et les radis nous
voulons du br nous voulons faire des
canons et pas de beurre vous vous allez
perdre la guerre je discute mon meilleur
ami c'était norte chargé d'affaires
damas à dahmane à pékin on joue au
bridge tous les soirs ils disent qu'il
est discuté en allemand et moi en
français mais c'était plus intéressant
du tpiy avait les hits aiea bd belge et
on voyait la fois que la phrase prenait
pas les mesures nécessaires pour la
guerre qui allait venu puisqu'il terre
nous avait dit en 33 qu'ils allaient le
déclarer la guerre il a écrit dans mon
cap d'une façon honnête il fallait être
ne plus avoir de raisons pour pas le
croire et on va en santé nous
profondément surtout aux contacts avec
l'étranger parce que savez on est
beaucoup plus français quand on est à
l'étranger où le savez c'est ce qu'on a
dit de beaucoup qu on sent beaucoup plus
les faiblesses de son pays que que ses
points forts en sorte et qu'on a les
caisses qui ne pensaient pas colonel que
si ces mesures sociales aussi avait été
prise plus tôt elle devrait contribuer à
faire une france beaucoup plus forte
moralement je suis absolument pas contre
le mur savoir où il fut temps normal ce
que j'ai je suis plus sur les pour
l'imposture sociale c'est pas ça c'est
parce que je critique je critique la
politique étrangère je peux donc pas la
politique intérieure qui m'intéresse je
suppliais re manche et llodra qui prend
part
vous posez votre question c'est ce qui
me frappe dans votre livre c'est que
c'est la certitude ce sont vos
certitudes vous ne remettez pas en doute
vos convictions de cette époque ça or
sur ce problème allemand par exemple
vous dit dès le début n'est ce pas
d'abord c'est le cartel des gauches
ensuite elle conte populaire tout cela
c'est évident nous n'avons pas eu
l'armée qu'il fallait n'est ce pas pour
pour affronter notre ennemi ghazir est
dit est hors jeu progresse aussi
avez vous réfléchi à ceci que site leur
est arrivé au pouvoir notamment
n'est ce pas en raison d'une certaine
politique de la france une politique
précisément le type de l'occupation de
la ruhr comment la république de weimar
a été empêchée pratiquement n'est ce pas
à cause d'une politique étrangère
extrêmement dures de la part de de la
france et de poincaré de vivre et
comment les hitler est arrivé au pouvoir
précisément sur le thème du nationalisme
à cause de la ruhr et à cause de toute
une politique étrangère qui était je
veux dire par là qu'on peut au moins se
poser la question
or dans votre livre n'est ce pas pourvus
c'est très simple et je crois que ce qui
est intéressant en vous lisant c'est
qu'on retrouve la vie de deux beaucoup
de gens certainement de beaucoup de
français et de beaucoup de gens de votre
génération très certainement sont selon
lesquelles tout est simple puisque à
partir de 24 le cartel puis à partir de
36 le front populaire explique tout
simplement la défaite française
non les colonels je suis pas c'est à
dire que ce court tout le monde pour
raconter ce qu'on pouvait lire on peut
raconter n'importe quoi à 10h mais je
crois qu'on s'énerve t pas sûr d'aller
du cradat ça dépend du point de vue au
11 mai moi je prends du point de vue
militaire et je vous ai dit au début je
parle des événements que j'ai vu du
poids mais je me trouvais comme je les
ai ressenti c'est un c'est un témoignage
que donne ce qu'odile je dis pas que ce
soit faux mais je donne le sentiment que
les gens de mon âge ont eu au moins où
il était et sur les éléments qu'ils ont
participé je suis pas content je sais
bien que c'est peut-être un petit
lepoint fr était trop sévère mais alors
peut-être pour théâtre sa façon les
poussières et le son sur lesquels on
peut aller on va demander le point carré
est en revanche on vous retrouve en
chine vous en avez parlé au début et
vous dites que vous êtes chargé de
maintenir je vous cite à situation
culturelle et morale de la france en
chine
mais pourquoi pas moi comment aussi s'il
voulait trop en quoi les non non 16
juillet à shanghai au point de vue
culturel avait situation il y avait les
universités de rome shanghai pour mon
chéri affaire qui former des médecins
des ingénieurs des pharmaciens qui avait
une renommée mondiale la liberté
l'europe à pékin il y avait une
université française qui avait remisé
mondiale nous jeudi les français oui oui
des chargés de mettre ne vous parle pas
d'économie vous parlez pas des intérêts
de la france économique et parce que la
france est dans la vie par là bas dont
la france et en ses rangs des cordes
le routard formidable de la france au
point de vue économique on avait une
concession énorme
omar derian français les allemands
gardaient les été mordue sauf les
français on se rendait compte du routard
fantastique de l'économie française ne
commettez pas capables demain en chine
les seules voitures qui avaient en chine
cette voiture des militaires ou de
l'ambassade alors toutes les autres
aussi on en délivrant des départs ferons
connaissez l'histoire
bon alors on va vous retrouver dans un
moment 58 donc vous êtes en poste en
chine j'en à la guerre ou 7 pétainiste
de gaulle ophelia les ennuis à la
libération puis vous entrez vous rentrez
en france vous vous créez donc les
bérets rouges puis vous être envoyé en
indochine je vais vite ce soir à x x
d'indochine et puis ensuite vous allez
en algérie on va vous retrouver en
algérie avec avec michel winock michel
winock donc vous comme j'ai dit et
voulant choisi d'aller au début de clic
vous avez des consuls ou d'une pendant
le front populaire vous êtes né en 37
pendant la grève n'est cependant les
grandes attentes en mars 1937 et puis
donc en 56 vous avez 19 ans vous êtes un
jeune intellectuel de gauche
quels sont les étudiants n'étaient plus
que l'étudiant enfin sollicités quels
sont les espoirs d'un jeune homme comme
vous en de 19 ans 20 ans espoirs
personnel oui bien sûr c'est un livre
personnel j'avais j'ai très peu de très
peu d'ambition je dois vous dire que
sortant du lycée je suis entré dans une
bulle romain poite d'import-export
pendant trois mois je me suis vraiment
ennuyé à mourir et j'ai eu la chance de
de trouver un moyen de m'en sortir
grâce à un tapir skin ans dans l'argot
étudiant veut dire grâce à un poste de
précepteur si vous voulez et j'ai pu
ainsi faire des études parce que j'avais
déjà vu quelques difficultés financières
ma mère étant veuve et c'est ainsi que
je me suis retrouvé à l'université la
sorbonne donc pour faire quoi je n'avais
aucune idée sinon je vais jamais j'avais
du goût pour la littérature pour pour
les lettres et je me suis mis à faire
une licence de lettres et puis un beau
jour je suis tombé sur tout à fait je me
suis un peu embêté tout de même un peu
comme monsieur qui fait l'ex d'ailleurs
qui raconte que les cours de littérature
française à la sorbonne n'est ce pas
dans les années 30 et est
prodigieusement ennuyeux et bien dans
les années 50 la sorbonne c'était la
même chance dans l'ensemble d'un sur la
houle alors à m queffélec sur les
parisiennes diaries
c'est vrai aussi dans les années 50 ans
et puis il y avait un certificat option
à l'époque c'était une licence ou un
certificat et je fais de l'histoire
comme cela pour voir ce que c'est et
j'ai eu une sorte de coup de foudre
parce que au lycée à l'époque nous
faisions de l'histoire je ne sais plus
tellement comment ça se passe
aujourd'hui mais au lycée c'était très
ennuyeux pour moi je trouve l histoire
quelque chose une discipline très
ennuyeuse qui consistait à bachoter
apprendre de la chronologie sait pas
faire de la chronologie c'était sans
intérêt
quelques bons professeurs nous nous
amusait nous intéressait mais ce n'était
pas une passion que j'ai acquise au
lycée et à la sorbonne là vraiment je
suis tombé oui dans des spas la sorbonne
c'est à l'époque l'époque encore des
grands amphithéâtres où devant 400
personnes il y avait des des maîtres qui
faisait des cours tout à fait
remarquable ex cathedra et quelques-uns
m'ont vraiment séduit et j'ai bifurqué
alors j'ai abandonné les les lettres
d'accord mais vous avez la tête
politique en même temps je peux
t'assurer très tôt quels sont justement
les espoirs d'un jeune homme de 19 ans
qui concerne la politique ont alors
scandé très très clair et très simple il
y avait une obsession l'algérie la
guerre d'algérie en effet comme nous
l'appelions alors qu'officiellement il
s'agissait de pacification la guerre
d'algérie commence comme vous savez en
novembre 2009 en handicap donc en 56 on
est des chats on est déjà dedans
jusqu'au cou ou l'appeler la sale guerre
oui la sale guerre enfin c'est pas moi
qui dit la sale guerre c'était une
expression des jambes
goyer oui à propos de l'indochine par le
parti communiste et la guerre d'algérie
était pour moi évidemment une sale
guerre comme les gammes indochine mais
j'étais trop jeune pour mieux être
vraiment passionné tout de même je dois
dire qu'en 1954 c'est de là que que
vient mon éveil politique et
l'intéressant c'est que c'est pas le
mien seulement mais de toute une partie
de ma génération 54,7 en effet dien ben
phu puis la fin de la guerre d'indochine
et cela
en raison n'est ce pas de l'arrivée au
pouvoir de pierre mendès-france et je
raconte par conséquent dans ce livre
comment nous lycéens nous avons été un
certain nombre de lycéens nous avons été
passionné par la politique avec
l'arrivée de pierre mendès-france
pouvoir guerre qui se traînait depuis
depuis des années qui nous paraissait
tout à fait archaïque et qui te fait
désolante n'est ce pas et il arrive et
il dit je fais la paix j'y arrive dans
30 jours n'est ce pas il estime que je
le dis oui mais c'est important si vous
voulez pour 54 oui mais à partir de ce
moment là je me passionne je m'intéresse
à jean-pierre le dantec lui dans son
livre que get bien de fou pour lui c'est
une victoire tête pour qui oui si on lui
dit je dis que je n'ai vécu j'ai vécu
dien ben phu
je m'appelle j'avais donc 11 ans j'étais
en cinquième et je me souviens très bien
dans les vestiaires du glee c'est qui ce
dans les combles d'un ancien monastère
avoir évoqué la question avec des amis
et moi j'étais tout à fait fier de la
victoire ddd pas très vieille dame hier
à ce moment là c'est tout à fait fier
sur les eaux sur les français j'avais eu
les couilles c'était une pour moi une
victoire de l'humanité sur l'inhumanité
c'est comme ça que vous parler
d'événement que vous avez vu de france a
c'est possible oui j'ai en plus j'avais
j'avais 11 ans mais sur ce point on
sentira on n'a pas un homme n'a pas
varié si vous voulez moi je dirais que
dix mois une trousse et je n'ai pas vécu
tout à fait de la même façon mais pour
moi ça a été le j'ai compris je crois
par dim bien fou que la décolonisation
était un processus historique disons
qu'ils allaient se développer et qui
allait avoir un terme qui était commencé
et que la france ne devait pas s'entêter
à se battre n'est ce pas dans des
guerres coloniales perdu d'avancé
non pas sur le terrain mais perdu
d'avancé politiquement parlant
et ça je pense que c'est une date aussi
sûrs qu'il continuera parce qu'on avait
reconnu la dalle et par des notes chine
depuis longtemps oui mais dans l'armée
vient d'en bien nous rendez pas compte
qu'ils avaient 90 70 à damien qui se
battait avec nous l'armée qui se
battaient nos schiste et hormis
vietnamienne y avait 58 le français
prend cadres et 400000 autochtone c'est
eux qui se sont battus et on avait
reconnu l'indépendance
avec elle les parents c'était un fait
accompli
nous nous battions contre le régime
communiste point c'est tout et nous
savions ce que le régime communiste
avait donné à leno chine et vous le
voyez aujourd'hui ce que ça donnait et
au cambodge
vous voyez nous savions que ça
arriverait comme ça c'est pour ça que
nous nous battions parce que nous nous
aimons les indochinois
nous avons une ère où meurent
d'infections pompe on passe pas son
existence avec des tables et des hommes
et des femmes sans les aimer
eh bien nous savions que les mettrai
dans la salade où ils sont aujourd'hui
et c'est pour ça que nous sommes battus
à sacha coulures amère donner un
dépanneur depuis longtemps on vous dit
jamais que l'armée qui s'est battue
c'était narbé indochinois à 80%
indochinois et dans des camps de dien
bien phu les prisonniers qui est
abaissée de coeur qu'ils allaient
ramasser défiler les pages et à aucun
s'est évadé aucun parti pouvait partir
et calt de les français sont partis ils
en salue tous leurs l'officier parce
qu'il y avait une affection pour nous ce
que vous voulez pas admettre écoulée
papa reconnaître c'est de savoir de
guerre d'indochine mais lâche vision la
question est la mienne est très complexe
est ce que je voulais dire n'est ce pas
c'est que le processus de la
décolonisation je veux fêter les records
pendant les concerts d'indochine les
teda corde raide une neige dure est le
phénomène de la décolonisation phénomène
général global universelle qui a
commencé on peut dire poursuites pour
donner une date à partir de 1918 79
n'est ce pas avec la naissance des
partis nationalistes dans tous les pays
coloniaux ou presque
et bien ce processus là vous vous êtes
vous n'avez pas compris c'est un jeu ni
aux détenus les bdt gerber moi j'attends
adressé à vivre auteur d'un livre que
j'ai lu et dans lequel apparemment vous
ne comprenez pas et ne voulait pas
admettre ce phénomène historique
en effet tout se passe comme si il y
avait et vous le dit explicitement
dirait jadis une france qui est un grand
pays et vous pleurez en des termes
parfaitement
honorable n'est ce pas sur la grandeur
de la france monsieur mais pour vous la
grandeur de la france telle qu'elle
apparaît dans votre livre c'est un
certain nombre de kilomètres carrés
n'est ce pas le plus le plus important
possible sur lesquelles le drapeau
français doit régner or je dois dire ce
qui me séparent profondément de vous et
je ne dis pas aujourd'hui mais déjà
lorsque j'avais 17 ans et que je pensais
que la grandeur de la france est bien
n'était pas proportionnelle précisément
vous trompez sous mes sentiments mais
audi dans le drapeau français
mais le drapeau français recourent
quelque chose recours des populations
pour lesquelles nous avons de
l'affection et que nous nous nous les
élever notre niveau c'est et ça me
semble que jeune nation
je ne conteste pas de consommer
territoire territoire c'est des mots je
voudrais terminer si vous voulez en vous
disant moi je ne je ne conteste pas du
tout le bien fondé de bons sentiments
là n'est pas la question je crois que
vous êtes attaché à une idée de la
grandeur française ça qui est du siècle
dernier qui est de jules ferry si vous
voulez mais qui n'est pas d'aujourd'hui
d'aujourd'hui des années 50 parce
qu'aujourd'hui la décolonisation s est
un processus qui est achevé à peu près
l'histoire pour ce qui est des français
et dans ce domaine il y a quelque chose
de troublant n'est ce pas en vous disant
c'est que j'ai à chaque fois à chaque
page dans chaque chapitre l'impression
que vous n'êtes pas mon contemporain que
vous êtes quelqu'un qui qui parle est
effectivement en des termes encore une
fois parfaitement honorable mais d'un
mille et al d'une france qui se mesure
eh bien oui quantitativement
quantitativement et non pas comment
dirais-je pour moi la grandeur d'un pays
où d'un candidat de la france était de
savoir résoudre un certain nombre de ces
problèmes de problème très concret très
matérielles les problèmes socio
économiques
mais aussi ce vaste problème qui était
précisément celui de la décolonisation
bon alors qu'est ce que vous faites pour
je ne sais pas pour hâter la paix en
algérie qu est ce qui vient tout d'abord
il faut vous dire que il y à une année
une année qui a été pour nous une année
terrible
c'est l'année 1956 parce que elle
commence par un espoir c'est l'élection
le 2 janvier 1956 d'un gouvernement de
gauche qui a fait toute sa propagande
toute sa campagne électorale sur le
thème de la paix en algérie
or il ya une petite déception chez
certains qui était l'un des six comme
moi n'est ce pas c'est qu'on lui
applique à mendès-france on appelle guy
mollet mais pourquoi pas qui mais après
tout il a derrière lui un grand parti
discipliné
ça peut être même une bonne chose or
vous savez ce qui s'est passé il y a eu
très rapidement cette désillusion le 6
février jaune à la journée donc c'est
une première déception et le début de
l'année 56 avait été marqué presque
simultanément
n'est ce pas par un autre espoir qui
était l'espoir de la déstalinisation il
y a eu en effet en février le 20ème
congrès du parti communiste de l'union
soviétique et on a vécu pendant quelques
temps c'est par cet espoir que le parti
communiste français et l'ensemble des
partis communistes alès distel lina lead
10 est analysée comme on disait c'est
difficile à dire est que pour la gauche
pour l'ensemble de la gauche
c'était une chose heureuse or nous avons
vécu la double désillusion n'est ce pas
de d'une part de la déstalinisation
manquer puisque dès le mois d'octobre
devant c'est l'épisode de la peste et
d'autre part ce gouvernement de gauche
qui est appelé pour faire la paix en
algérie et qui va faire une politique de
guerre en algérie qui va se concrétiser
par l'expédition de suez
or chose tout à fait inouï et même assez
rare tout cela va se passer en même
temps au cours de 7 octobre novembre
pour de cet automne en 1956
simultanément il va vous il va y avoir
l'expédition de port saïd
d'une part n'est ce pas qui était comme
le dit le colonel trinquier un prétexte
aux niçois la finalisation du canal de
suez avaient été peintes prétexte c'est
pour l'ouvrir d'accord c'est sur ce
point j'avais relevé ce mot de prétextes
je suis tout à fait d'accord
les deux accords ce berger et il
s'agissait d' dans l'expédition de port
saïd n'est ce pas d'atteindre l'état
major du félidé xarlas pas dit non c'est
non pas autre chose
donc nous vivions cela et en même temps
l'affreuse répression de budapest et ce
par les chars soviétiques qui arrivait à
budapest et ceux qui étaient plus
pénible certainement c'est que chez ces
étudiants donc de gauche et
anticolonialiste les camarades qui je
militais pour la paix en algérie c'était
des communistes des étudiants
communistes et ceci n'est ce pas
descendait défend des plus ou moins
d'ailleurs mais défendent est
officiellement en tout cas là
l'intervention des chars soviétiques à
budapest et s'étaient par conséquent
extrêmement douloureux alors tout cela
se passait de ce pendant une année et
parfois même dans des séquences
temporelles extrêmement extrêmement
étroite
c'était très dramatique est une
formation politique évidemment c'était
important
et puis la torture en algérie ça c'est
puel qui malgré les 1 8 parce que trop
mans paris vers 58 157 n'est ce pas que
le scandale de la torture éclate et pour
nous ça a été pour nous un pour
l'ensemble des français je suppose
c'était quelque chose de bouleversant
d'abord parce que
bon nous étions dans une république qui
avait certains principes qu'ils aient
proclamait qui depuis la révolution
française même se faisaient le champion
championne d'espagne de ses principes et
qui ne les respectait pas dans sa propre
dans son propre territoire et dans sa
guerre coloniale alors on pourrait
discuter du bien fondé de la guerre
coloniale mais il y avait là un principe
absolu intangibles à mes yeux n'est ce
pas qu'on n'avait pas le droit de
bafouer qui était le respect de la
personne humaine même sur l'adversaire
sur la personne de l'adversaire lorsque
à partir de 1956 57 des camarades de
plus âgé que nous sont revenus une
algérie qu il est d appeler ou des
rappelés et qui ne sont mis à parler et
à écrire
et ces témoignages ont circulé certains
ont été publiés
les journaux étaient saisis les journaux
et des saisies des revues été saisis
mais malgré tout n'est ce pas nous
reproduisions d'une manière ou d'une
autre ces textes une fusion circuler et
on peut dire que dans tout le quartier
latin la campagne sur le thème de la
torture a été une campagne extrêmement
là vous avez dû être particulièrement
intéressé par le passage où ils chapitre
où le grain qui raconte donc votre
action à ce moment là pour pacifier la
casbah d'alger sous les ordres du jeu
donné j'ai pas voulu raconter tout ce
qui a été raconté sur la beauté du jeu
donnait grandes lignes dans laquelle
elle était conduite
alors vous avez joué un rôle très
important et chez terry jeunes
généralement si j'étais jeune et amassé
en plus j'étais en permanence à la
préfecture et avec monsieur t jane comme
je t'ai jane ses plaies après qui sait
pas ce qui se passait mais on avait fixé
l'arrêt dans l'état-major tous les jours
de 14 heures à la préfecture tous les
officiers étaient là le préfet de venir
aucun civil et donné des jeunes en plus
chargé de la police alors quand par
hasard y venaient ma sucrier tiendra
mais ce mix qui arrive c'est l'état
major mixte et partez tout se discute
est sur la table mais moi j'étais en
perdant à sa préfecture avec lui je ris
et tous les pots amis qui dit n'y aurait
rien à lasser des choses qui vous ont
étonné dans le récit de
hé hé
peut-être des silences non j'ai écrit si
vous voulez rouler on compare de la
tortue oui mais ça me dérange pas du
tout d'en parler comme je pourrais être
content torture c'est très facile à vous
êtes sûrs comme se plaisent à revoir
tout de suite en mauvais satisfaction
c'est très commun et bien je suis allé
répondre de trois ans au gaucher de
sciences po et dassault bon forcément
opposé à tout rompre la question voilà
ce que je leur ai répondu il ya eu la
torture il ya eu des tortues en gênera
c'est le fait de très mauvaise toux peut
être très mauvais des troupes est mal
encadré mal commandé par leurs officiers
c'est arrivé c'était arrivé on a été
obligés d'éponger la faire il ya des cas
où je vous posais aka qui m'est arrivé
ou dire est ce qu il fait j'ai pensé ça
aux étudiants puis arrêt dit vous aurez
pu être officiers de réserve
vous voudrez peut être vous aurait pu
être dans mon régiment parce que les
parachutistes qu'on appelait en appeler
l'armée de métier mais des parachutes y
avait 90% d'appeler y avait pas mal géré
une armée une armée de métier et le
deuxième qui a sauté à succès telles
armes et d'appeler bon eh bien je vais
dire d'après midi ont arrêté un poseur
de bombe
il y avait encore une sur lui il en a
posé une deux trois quatre ou démonter
la bombe ces projets relais fait pour ce
test est réduit de l'après midi il est
là vous savez qu'une bombe casino achats
à cornish a fait 10 morts et 40 blessés
si la pose et si du fait multiplication
60 morts 300 blessés review pour avertir
le cardinal qui convoque tous ces curés
pour les combats c'est des moments vous
en avez un paquet et toutes les
ambulances
il est là qu est ce que vous faites pas
un mot à mot moi j'aimerais habiter
alors il faut prendre une décision qu
est ce que vous auriez fait ou bon tout
d'abord je vous dirai ça serait très
prétentieux de ma part de vous dire moi
j'aurais fait ça parce que vous avez
parfaitement de raisons de venir
c'est facile quand on est très loin il
faut normaliser bon je suis d'accord
donc sur ce point que je ne peux pas
vous répondre
dix ans j'aurais fait ceci ou cela
présomption donc je ne vous répond pas
sur ce point ce que je peux vous dire
c'est que il y a des principes qui sont
absolus comme je le disais tout à
l'heure un temps j y ai des choses qu'on
ne doit pas faire qu'on ne doit pas
faire et si on l'a fait parce que il y à
des cas où ma foi ça serait il ne faut
pas le couvrir il faut il faut
absolument s'efforcer de deux d'empêcher
cette chose or ces quatre torture qui
ont été très nombreux ont été couverts
par les autorités et pas seulement l'âge
ce n'est pas l'armé du tout qui est ce
n'est pas l'armée seulement t exactement
qui est en cause
il ya aussi la gendarmerie oui si vous
voulez mais y'a aussi avant tout
le gouvernement politique les pouvoirs
politiques or un gouvernement qui couvre
ses actes
il est responsable et c'est bien
l'impression que nous avions n'est ce
pas que ces textes
oui j'aimerais vous voulez répondre à la
question vous finirez amende explication
parce que d'évidence c'est que
normalement on ne devait pas se trouver
dans ce genre de situation c'est à dire
si on n'était pas là bas si si on n'est
pas poursuivre une politique coloniale
comme l'a suivi on n'avait aucune raison
jamais aussi mal six premiers et
deuxièmes deuxième point je discutais il
ya peu avec un de vos anciens supérieurs
que je sache le général de bollardière
l'iodé mieux que vous est peut-être
passé c'est simple et 12 possibles et
rainbow six
c'est possible qu'ils lui que je sache
en tout cas une position morale strict
et a refusé de s'engager sur ce terrain
de la torture au point que je sache il a
dû être cassés de son commandement et
faire un certain nombre de deux mois de
ses exportations du système ou qu'on ne
sait pas mon ordi
féret le brésil est pas là mais je finis
mon historique et bien moi j'ai des mois
je suis prêt à le couper en petits
morceaux pour que ce soit n'est pas 40
et type tués et 60 blessés parce que
c'est moi qui serai soir ma fin de
course
alors voilà comment saisir dernier non
on n'a pas coupé personnes je vous
raconte l'histoire de robin et le
connais bigeard godard et moi deux
soeurs nous on était le sort duquel nous
la corniche à mes 12 morts et des
blessés quand j'avais 18 ans et qu au
moins qu'une pièce est très agréable et
vous savez il faut que vous empêcher que
ça arrive aux gens alors on a pensé que
tout les bons hommes étaient d'anciens
grands cahill laquelle nous sommes allés
tous les toits nous sommes allés chez
lui et bigeard a dit les bornes sont
chez toi je dis comme à moi officier de
la légion d'honneur ou me soupçonner
bigeard leurs tanks et l'egypte face aux
mêmes heures il attendait il a ouvert
une ville et bob était derrière voilà
souvent procès s'est amené la torture
c'est ça il faut qu'à un moment donné
les gens qui sont contre vous qui savons
mais pression que vous voulez ce qu'ils
disent bon ça renonçant maintenant
est-ce que les temps passe michel winock
le 13 mai 58 l'appel général de gaulle
évidemment vous êtes contre vous êtes
contre et vous dites de metz de massue
que c'est un général factieux donc comme
je suppose qu'il connaît le train qui
était lui aussi dans le comité de salut
public vous poser comme un colonel
factieux chaussures d'ailleurs le
colonel trinquier le dit lui même car il
écrit un chapitre qui s'appelle le coup
d'état y faisait par conséquent et j'ai
appelé ça le coup d'état le premier le
seul qui a donné ce nom parce que je
connais bien à faire exactement et vous
le racontez d'ailleurs très bien c'est
un épisode tout à fait passionnant du
livre et je crois que vous devez vous ne
mentez pas du tout premier plan et vous
raconter très bien comment à partir
d'alger mais il était bien question
d'une expédition à paris n'est ce pas
est de prendre le pouvoir en métropole
donc vous serez vous dites même
oui nous avons rénové une frustration il
voulait venir en fumée le palais bourbon
c'était le cri corner alors donc si ce
n'est pas nocif action celle avec
anthony on voulait pas prendre le
pouvoir
parce que si j'écris un nouveau livre je
le trouvais sur ce thème là prendre
pouvoir c'est difficile nous avions le
pouvoir ne savais pas qu'en faire
qu'est-ce que vous prenez pas le plus
c'est vrai et je vous dis la vérité vous
débouchez passe au poiré mater décemment
opération car mon appart a fait le coup
d'état de huit premières ilham et sieyès
roger du quota iran le soir ils avaient
qu'à s'asseoir au bout de la table et
présidé un conseil 2009 c'était pas ça
du tout on s'est rendu compte
on a été poussé par les événements ont
été poussés par les vents moi je pensais
pas du tout quand j'étais à mon bureau à
14 après midi que j'allais prendre
gouvernement général 5h je les prix
parce que j'ai été poussé par vous avez
la foux jour à caen rue ils m'ont porté
sur leurs épaules gouvernement général
massu bedie ils veulent qu'on fasse un
comité s'est fait d'accord j'ai dit oui
comme ça mais d'autres disent on dit non
pas beaucoup ont dit non vous le
raconter oui beaucoup en jouant beaucoup
ont dit non parce que c'est là si vous
voulez les trouillards les prières qui
attendent que le coût soit jouer pour
jouer pour jouer le coup après tout le
monde était pour l'algérie jouer tous
les généraux venir faire leur pitch
alors qu'une semaine avant
il sait tout faire et rien du tout
bonjour ça j'ai vu la valeur programme
de mai en avril en avril 61
vous n'êtes pas alger sinon là vous êtes
en train je crois de visiter le musée
d'athènes où le parthénon et oui et vous
n'êtes donc pas dans le coup mais vous
dites clairement je suis partisan de ce
putsch et au fond c'est bien dommage que
je n'y sois pas là oui mais attendez à
ben non avant on m'a contacté on m'a
contacté en me dit est ce que voulaient
venir par est gênant dans une pâle donc
c'est pas la peine de le dire moi j'ai
dit le pouce et u9 c'est une question de
volonté de force
le 13 mai quand j'ai appris comme des
lapins gouvernement général j'avais pas
envie moi un matin de faire fusiller
dans les fossiles vincennes gérard
salommez officiers je savais qu'on avait
alerté le liseur mécanique rapide pau
venir par gouvernement général je
rassemble mes objets ont été chargés des
bazookas les sacs à terre on ne tirait
sur le premier char qui venait c'était
une motion pour moi il n'est pas venu
parce qu'ils savaient que j'avais tiré
sur lui alors tous les gens france ont
conclu que le xiii bis à cet effet sans
aucune opposition et je disais ce qu'ils
voulaient le faire des tonnes il y aura
une épreuve de force pour que vous soyez
détails de la surmonter
j'ai dit si en allant aux aides d'état
et 800 mille hommes je vais avec vous je
veux pas dire tuer cent mille ans mais
si vous donnez l'impression qu'on me
laisse jusqu'au bout ou réussir et si
vous dites coutu l'armée tire pas sur
mes ou perdre et je vais pas avec nous
il n'empêche nous qui avait toujours été
anti gaulliste
vous participez d'un conte qualité au
comité de salut public de 58 qui l'a
amené le général de gaulle aux affaires
vous vous êtes anti gaulliste aussi vous
avez toujours voté contre charles de
gaulle et à la fin de votre ouvrage
temps d en 58 g pas toujours venu et
après contre général ont la preuve
contre eux et à la fin de votre lit vous
rendez une certaine manière au
management général de gaulle disant
qu'il a fait ce que la gauche n'a pas pu
faire ce qui fait que voilà deux anti
gaulliste l'un ramène le général de
gaulle aux affaires il y contribue
vous vous êtes opposé toujours à lui et
vous lui rendez hommage est il celui là
évidemment est tout à fait contre il
vous regrettez évidemment d'avoir oui
j'ai rien faire nous mêmes le premier
jour j'ai regrettés parce que les
événements vont vite et quand vous êtes
dans un lieu dans une voie ou plus par
sortir enfin si j'ose dire général massu
il vous a eu si vous n'avez jamais dit
qu'il veut je n'avais jamais fait pour
le retour vertueux moi ou il a dit ça on
prépara peut pas faire de ne pouvait pas
se diviser alors que tout le monde était
contre finalement ces jeunes avaient
négligé de suivre
cela suggère même astuce après massue si
vous voulez
on a critiqué beaucoup massue c'est un
honnête homme un homme qui a beaucoup de
bon sens il a senti que danse ils
étaient perdus dans ce match est que il
ya les personnes qui s'adressaient enfin
il faut pour être honnête aussi quel est
l'homme qui on aurait pu faire appel
selon la même et anti gaulier étendait
la quatrième république je crois que
l'on nous reproche de l'avoir flanquer
par terre mais personne défense régime
ou et quelqu'un aujourd'hui qui va
défendre la 4ème république personne le
seul c'était de vol on s'est accroché à
lui je suis là non non ce que la langue
non parce qu'il faut bien dire